فقدان المظاهرات في ايران لزخمها المعتاد
او انخمادها وصفا يرفض الايرانيون الذين
يؤكدون ان احتجاجاتهم ضد النظام لم تهدا
اوصفه واوضح متظاهرون ان المتغير الوحيد
هو واستراتيجيات التجمع والتحرك فقط
لاسباب عداء اولها اساليب القمع المتزايده
من الاجهزه الامنيه بالاضافه طبعا لظروف
الجويه القاسيه وانشغال الايرانيين
بالفتره الماضيه بازمه نقص الغاز والوقود
لكن العجز عن تامين التدفئه والخبز وما
شابه يزيد النقد الشعبيه والتظاهرات التي
دخلت مرحله جديده مظاهرات ليليه محدوده مع
كتابه الشعارات على الجدران ووفقه ايران
انترناشونال كتابه الشعارات المناهضه
للنظام تتوسع بشكل ملحوظ خصوصا في مشهد في
مدينه مشهد وسط جهود من السلطات لمحوها
قبل الانتشار فيما الشعرات تتردد ليلى حتى
من نوافذ المنازل في العاصمه طهران ومناطق
محيطه بينها همم نار مارك وايضا مدن اخرى
بالتوازي طبعا مع حرق صور رموز النظام
ومهاجمه مقر البسيج مشاهدينا تشير
التقارير هنا تقارير جديده الى استمرار
الاعتقالات التعسفيه وتعذيب السجناء
والضغط على عائلاتهم من بين هذه العائلات
ومن بينهم المواطن محسن تهمه ثابت الذي
اعتقل في نوفمبر كما يواصل القضاء
الايراني ممارسه الضغط على السجناء
المعرضين لخطر الاعدام باللجوء الى تهمه
الافساد
[موسيقى]